histoire une forme le chauffeur voulait
se suicider il est parti à roye
déceptions sentimentales mais il notre
franck sortait du plaza où devait faire
sean connery et le jeu rentre dans le
taxi et oui j'aime bien l'aéroport une
course où j'allais dans le 6ème
arrondissement ils veulent en tout le
trajet le dis [ __ ] je n'arrête pas de
me taper des mers dévoile à lui devant
il a la belle course je ne sais plus
mais fragile a répété je me tape une
merde et on regarde bien encore abel
morini bosc est avec nous ce soir dans
cet habitat on nettoie lettres et
d'histoire de taxi moi c'est ma vie le
taxi j'ai palpé les maghrébins non non
non 1
vous avez une histoire vous n'aurez eyes
ou non le gars m'a expulsé lui taxi ah
oui parce que j'ai fait comme un pari
ben c'est leur vie n'a droit qu'à gauche
prévoir un connaît la route etc
j'ai parlé en anglais on était à londres
il m'a dit monsieur ça ne se fait pas il
m'adore et du taxi s'il vous plaît est
ce que maintient une bonne histoire
c'est tout ce que je devrais je ne
manque pas grand-chose bordel non
vraiment pas benjamin non c'est pas mal
alors que dehors il va rentrer alors
j'avais une dette non pas de culot n'y a
pas de fumée non armés taxi alors ils
étaient partout encore un texte qui peut
tout faire
non j'ai rencontré des gens alors tout
mais pas dans un taxi alors m écoute
anecdotes des bolides
je monte dans le taxi tu dis boulane
s'il vous plaît il m'a dit non je peux
pas de sac et tu dégages voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sa course est la plus con c'est comme un
bisou au frère en parlant de je peux pas
de sac et non mais par l'eau mais tu
sais qu'on va dans la même salle de
sport que ce monsieur nantes malick ba
ouai mais qu'on ne se voit jamais non
mais parce que cette personne passe
devant tout le monde et va s'entraîner
dans une pièce secrète des vrais
finances arrêtons de se voit jamais
alors que nous on te voit passer et m'a
dit qu'il me fallait textron dire le
conte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]